since you want to play this is giving
arcades
1999 we're coming for you
what's up guys my name is curly and as
you know i love fashion so today we are
hanging out here at this amazing vintage
store to thrift a 90s look but i need a
little bit of help so i decided to call
the homegirl over in bel air miss coco
jones the singer songwriter actress
goddess hilary banks 2.0
wow you look so beautiful this is
amazing thank you wait who's this bye
this is ricky brazil like a little spin
you know i mean i can if that's what
we're doing here well today i'm gonna
actually need a little bit of your help
i want to do like a 90s inspired fresh
prince look
but i am super like almost allergic to
color i only wear earth tones and i want
to live this life forever so i'm like
let's do it okay well then it's a color
day i haven't styled in a while either
way it's going to give in west
philadelphia born and raised all righty
babes let's go do this let's do some
shopping let's get you cute all right
let's do it after you thank you darling
how would you describe your style in
three words classy
sexy lively as i'm coming of age i'm
getting into my sexy background yeah and
like trying also to wake the girls up
but not like alarm what does this mean
wake the girls up like i'm grown but not
like i'm grown now it's like
i thought for a second we were talking
about our boobs no not them girls
okay so i'm seeing a lot of overalls
over here yes that's super 90s okay
these are these are giving 90s are they
i mean they're baby blue you know would
you date a guy who was in these overalls
i would need to see the swag because i
don't know if i want hip to the hot to
get into the hippie you know who looks
really good in overalls tupac
hey dan all five two of him he's not
five two hey siri how tall was tupac
tupac shakur was five feet nine inches
tall oh
i knew his energy was up there
yeah let's get you some color i like her
that's good you know that's very pop of
color i mean it's giving me a little bit
of a minion which i'm not surprised so
they know capricorns uh like to sabotage
virgos all the time oh is it giving
saboteur since you want to play this is
this is giving arcades you want to play
games i love this for you you know they
did daring stuff in the 90s it was about
standing out and this is giving red
alert
hillary banks is kind of known for being
super iconic in fashion always
and i feel like you're kind of bringing
it again as well and kind of redoing it
in your own way how much input are you
having in hillary's look now i feel like
i do have a lot of input fernando
rodriguez was the stylist i remember i
was the first one to get styled and when
i walked in there i was like gasps have
you taken anything no they'd be watching
me like a hulk oh did you try to embody
hillary banks when you auditioned for
her i mean yeah i think i did it kind of
wrong though because i was basing my
audition off of og hillary yeah and in
bel air she's much more like grounded
she's more goal-oriented
so i was kind of playing it more like
and morgan cooper our director he was
like no so then what happened he was
like be
what you are like be the star that you
are and i was like oh i could do that
for free yeah but i would do it for a
check as well i've told you this already
before often on camera that your
personality is popping this is how she
actually is like yeah
thank you this is real
[Music]
giving me for such a on the floor yes
wait
curly
oh
my god this could be cute we definitely
have to try on we have to try it we've
got a couple looks now
what are some like pieces that you have
to have in your wardrobe i have to have
a good pair of jeans
a good black heel and i do a lot of crop
tops i feel like that's the easy one you
have to show that off you have to show
your finger off
i think yeah yeah you have a piece that
you can't live without i would say i
just actually got these leather pants
because you know leather pants at the
moment right now i just got these
himulat lang i don't know how to
pronounce oh like helmet length yeah oh
yeah the quality is wow
i hope so where is the helmet length aka
i was like vibes is it expensive sidebar
you also can sing and i don't mean like
you can hold like a no i mean like you
can sing i try i try how many times do
people make you like sing all the time
i'm not gonna make you do because i feel
like sometimes people always like dang
actually what's funny is my mom used to
do this thing when we were in meetings
and she would rub her earring and that
means you need to sing
yeah so like all the time
so you have a new song called caliber
yeah yeah i was wondering if you meant
like high caliber or like a gun it's not
giving guns blazing all right i was kind
of hoping it was it's giving high
caliber this guy's trying to talk to me
and i'm like okay that's cute and
everything but like you're gonna have to
level up because i'm a boss
yes yes yes what do you think about this
style
so you tweeted in 2021 september 16 this
girl shouted coco coco jones while i was
on a date and i told this man i work at
buzzfeed
wait that's hilarious because i'm
actually here
hey guys co-workers hi oh my god that is
so funny okay so backstory i don't like
to tell people that i sing if i feel
like they don't already know it because
one time i told this guy and he was like
oh you gonna sing and ever since then
i'm like
i make up things i say i work at my
parents construction company i say i
just moved here look at her job i say
model and then when they find out
they're like wait you you really sing
though i'm like let's see if you switch
out oh wow yeah so i i did tell him i
worked at buzzy what made you pick
frisbee winter oh
i was like yeah buzzfeed i mean it's so
fun like i get to be creative you know
come up with a lot of ideas and then
this girl she was like coco
coco jones that's always how they do the
second one yeah coco jones you got me
yeah i'm into culture
no we're in the 90s
what about wildest dreams for your music
where do you like hope it takes you i
mean i feel like i'm in a wild ass dream
if i could take it more i want to do
like world tours international so what
looks do you think that you would go for
on stage i really love like a bodysuit
type of like a jumpsuit type yeah i like
glitter and sparkle too it just reminds
me of when i was younger and i literally
looked like a actual rhinestone i try to
incorporate black designers i love me
some laquan smith jessica rich i wear a
lot of her shoes oh yeah so amazing i
feel like you would like patrick kelly
you should totally check patrick kelly
out he was the first black american to
go high fashion in like the 80s
[Music]
oh hi
i'm putting on some of your um
choices yay questionable oh
you're the creator of the you would do
it too for a check i could do that for
free yeah but i would do it for a check
as well yeah i did say that so i'm gonna
ask you what would you actually do for a
check okay not just anything oh i would
do anything for each other anything
would you tell your ex-boyfriend's new
girlfriend that she's hotter than you
for a check name your price for me to
say to my ex his girl yeah you're hotter
than me yes i'm gonna need at least 50
bears 50. yes i would do it for a good
50 dollars
um this is giving
don't have your driver's license yet
almost turning 16. it's also giving
bold cuts for some reason maybe it's
just so much chaos here that i can't i
can't vibe with the rest because i'm not
mad here you're mad but i feel like
super angry here this is like ronald
mcdonald vibes to me like wrong
oh the zip up made it even worse in some
way
how do straight guys flirt
they don't pose like that start
that's giving teacher helping with
homework this was your choice i thought
it was gonna be something different i
thought wrong
okay next question since hillary's a
chef would you eat a meal with like a
big nasty hair in it what no
why girlie what are you saying you have
your whole extensions in my plate
seriously okay that's a health hazard
vibes are we ready almost ready because
i'm ready to judge okay babes here we go
oh my gosh turn around babes whoo yes
let me see the bag
i love the one shoulder off is that swag
this is hot
with the jewelry it's giving cool ass
rapper dude yes giving ll cool and jay
well that pose is giving me disco okay
yeah
[Applause]
i think we're on a roll now so this next
one's really gonna give all right babes
this is the final look impress me i'm
bored already
babes a lot of accessories let's go
and then
let's touch it
oh
this is giving me the swag that i didn't
know
i needed i feel like my dad has this
outfit and there's this picture
somewhere in the attic gathering dust
yes where he's wearing this with a chain
and it's giving swag nice it's giving me
tasteful if you dress like this and you
see coco jones on public go and spit
games not if i have this fur on if if
i'm wearing this fur you're better off
not addressing it but no i do love this
this is definitely a fresh prince era
very very very layer of view beautiful
should we do a catwalk yes
let's do this where are we walking to
because it's like a dead end
[Music]
[Music]
yes i think we've done it mission is
accomplished now thank you so much
you're welcome all right gonna go back
to my job at buzzfeed well enjoy it
thank you well what'd you think how'd
you think we did she thinks we did great
even though this isn't necessarily like
a curly look it's definitely on brand
with like a 90s fresh prince look so i'm
ready i'm ready for the party
[Music]